well you know athletic injuries have
really increased in incidents over the
last 20 years in a very rapid rate now
why is that well I think that first and
foremost the reason is that more and
more people are involved in athletics
just bottom line you see athletics
they're being being organized athletics
starting when when children are just in
elementary school right its extensive
throughout you know they're only the
elementary school middle school high
school is a explosion of college
athletics and all different all
different sports and then it is
recreational sports more and more people
are involved in it in addition they're
also involved in it to a much greater
degree in later years it's not unheard
of to have people in there it used to be
that somebody tore their anterior
cruciate ligament which is a key
stabilizing ligament to the knee you
expected that to be somebody in their
20s maybe the early 30s and then you
would consider replacing it now I see my
colleagues operating on people in their
40s even earlier early 50s with anterior
cruciate ligament tears who need that
ligament intact to be able to
participate in the sports that they want
to so there has been a great growth in
the athletic participation and you add
to that what's also done is it's not
just men that are doing it it's women
women are actively involved in athletics
so we've now seen kind of a blurring of
the lines between who gets what kind of
injury now now it's true men are tend to
be much more involved in contact sports
so there's certain types of injuries
there but women are more and more
involved in athletics and we found that
certain aspects of of women's anatomy
predispose them to certain injuries for
instance anterior cruciate ligament
injuries in soccer players or other
cutting type sports there's there's
differences in the female anatomy that
has led to an increased incidence of
what we call non-contact ACL tears
anterior cruciate ligament tears whereas
in men oftentimes it has to do with a
getting hit and injury of pivoting a
pivoting injury you know on a football
field or on a basketball court but this
but women it tends to be
contact and what we understand that the
more we can hopefully develop trends to
to prevent it
the third area is the fact that that
kids are involved in so many sports but
they tend to focus on the sport
year-round now but when I when I was
growing up you kind of played football
or soccer in the fall played basketball
in the winter and then played baseball
in the summer or in the warmer weather
in this in the climate in New York now
if cific a boy or girl is good in
basketball well they're playing on you
know AAU team in the fall then the
school team in the in the winter and
then going back to an au or a clora a
travel team you know in the in the
spring and the summer so they're playing
one sport now and that takes its toll on
the specific body parts involved so for
example some of the problems with
baseball players elbow injuries tearing
the collateral ligament the ulnar
collateral ligament which is the
ligament on the inside of your elbow
here the so called Tommy John surgery
that's necessary to reconstruct that
ligament used to be you know listen
before Frank Jobe did that procedure in
Tommy John it was almost unheard of now
you start the scene these injuries and
high school players sometimes even
younger because they're playing the
sports year-round and it's taking its
toll the mechanics may not be exact
right increased stresses so that's one
thing you have to be very careful of
this the athletic stresses that we
subject children to during their during
their growing years and the impact on
this skeleton as well as the soft
tissues
well obesity is a significant problem in
this country right I mean you see that
in the newspapers and the medical
journals it is an issue and I say that
to you now two days after my own
physician told me that I needed to lose
ten percent of my body weight so um
speaking from experience here but there
is no doubt that obesity carries a takes
its toll on the wear and tear on the
joints and it clearly is a risk factor
for the development of the Jenner of
arthritis but even more so all right the
let's say you developed a Jenner of
arthritis in the new year at a hip and
and you have significant obesity a
successful hip or knee replacement is
certainly possible but their risk
factors are greater the chance of
complications are greater when in
patients that are obese than those that
are not obese with respect to you know
cardiac pulmonary and other
complications so it has it has an impact
not only on the development of the
problem but also in the ability to
effectively treat it and have a
successful result